sticky jelly got my dick HR I was his
name mr. martini mr. martini mr. martini
God my home you first moved to 88th
Street that's the first thing the kid to
tell you like I was sleeping this guy
don't [ __ ] up mr. martini oh Jesus he's
a monster in his nearby a teeny wore
black suit with a white shirt and black
shoes as a wife would die and he owned
the building on 88th Street in the
middle and he was angry and he would
sweep and you know like when you were a
kid and you stopped in front of
somebody's house he would always come
out and go get the [ __ ] out of here you
little [ __ ] douchebags
get the [ __ ] I was Cuban I didn't
understand the language I didn't really
understand what he was saying I
understood the anger but I don't
understand the language he would come
out with a broom get the [ __ ] out of
here one day I realize I'm like this
[ __ ] wants to rock so while my
other friends didn't wanna [ __ ] him
I'm like we're gonna [ __ ] with this
[ __ ]
so all Cubans have been like water in
front of their house and there's
something that your mother throws change
and every day yeah it's like a good luck
statue I would steal the change and
bring it downstairs and I would look at
the poorer kids and I go come in for
saying you want a corner never go yeah
we'll get a quarter I would take a
quarter to throw it when mr. martini
lived mmm he lived like in a basement
area and when he ran the whole bit he'd
be right there
and he'd chase us we go mr. martini
something like weeny in the [ __ ]
chases huggy chases he caught you
he would [ __ ] hit you like 50 times
but we [ __ ] him up we would [ __ ] him
up dog I saw some [ __ ]
the first day like New Jersey to me was
it completely
that was like Mars to most people I
think most people listen to me and go
you grew up someplace that doesn't exist
I'll bring eight people to fill these
chairs to tell you about the parents and
the people and the situations but the
first day I went out in my hometown of
Bergen I saw me and Joe Rogan fight and
even though I had Joe Rogan on his back
I saw Joe Rogan's father come down the
stairs pull me off Joe Rogan
like me punch me kick me throw me on the
floor and make his kids go in that was
my first experience ever in North Bergen
New Jersey and so a million mr. Robson
come downstairs
he took Anthony off his son threw him
off smacked him in the [ __ ] face joe
rogan at two and he have to [ __ ] noon
in ninety degree he punched him in the
stomach and tell him to go home you
little Guinea [ __ ] go home you little
Guinea [ __ ] say that now they'll throw
you in jail for two years he throw him
go home you little Guinea [ __ ]
Anthony look at him crying a little bit
he picked up his shirt he went like this
like he took the thing off and he was
I'm calling my [ __ ] father you're
[ __ ] dead [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ] Guinea [ __ ] [ __ ]
father died a he's probably a [ __ ]
just like you and I'm sitting there
going I want to see how this plays out
and next thing you know two cop cars
pull up and there's one cop car that's
unmarked it's another one that's marked
and it's a big [ __ ] Italian with him
detective like you know the short stumpy
Italian and he comes out of his car I
put his [ __ ] jacket on it barely fits
but till this Dara member the
mortadella's he had on his hand he goes
what the [ __ ] going on here kids the
[ __ ] mr. Robson came at me and he
[ __ ] smacked me in the face these are
my witnesses Talib didn't he [ __ ] hit
me and I'm sitting there going on this
is gonna get [ __ ] good the [ __ ]
cop the detective tells the cop go look
around see if there's tickets go spread
tickets and he goes where's this guy
live and he goes and he goes he grabbed
all the other kids he goes tell me what
happened and he goes Anthony and him
were fighting and he came back and he
[ __ ] pulled them and that this time
they know that could the cops are there
I'm mister Robson I kind of opened this
door to be kind of tough like he's not
coming up here he's only normal [ __ ]
knock him out - and the cop goes okay
I'm okay okay leave grabbed the kid
because you're okay right yeah because
he just hit me in the face and he
[ __ ] walked up the stairs bro
I'm five minutes got to the top thing I
open the [ __ ] door
Joe Rogan this guy will put his hand
then pull the ball
[ __ ] put him against the [ __ ]
thing on the second floor with everybody
out and just started punching him Oh
punching him punching him like [ __ ]
John Jones this one he's got you down
he's hitting you with those shots to the
head until the guy killed though and
they started kicking him with the
[ __ ] thing bam bam bam
gonna go don't you ever [ __ ] hit my
son again let's get out of here well
that was how I became friends with the
family because soon as he came down he
goes who was this kid because he's the
spicket he's the only one that jumped in
because you want to come home for dinner
and that was the beginning of my life
when I got in that police car because I
did raise it whatever I did whatever the
[ __ ] I want
till today this is [ __ ] crazy and you
know me and you don't [ __ ] around what
do you got over there this is still
that's what happened in nineteen seventy
[ __ ] three and what's that today
that's a a gold card what does this card
do it it does what it will need it to do
it does whatever I needed to do you know
I'm saying you're a family member did
why because of that [ __ ] day cuz I'm
the only guy that jumped it I like how
cops have things like that a family
member one of your buddies is a cop show
get pulled over put this on your license
plate this little sneaky little thing so
now what type I'm eating at the house
I'm eating [ __ ] pasta we had the
middle oh I could open up the front door
whenever I want I call the mama she
makes cream puffs
oh I'm tight with them I'm the only
Cuban in 1974 that's even walking in
there so now we're in the sixth grade
and we're playing kickball McKinley had
no fun remember two months ago how long
the generous donated 50,000 to a grandma
school was my grandma school North
Bergen New Jersey months ago yeah one
degeneres donated fifty thousand
now when I went to that grammar school
those [ __ ] didn't have a Jim
Joe Road you shovel snow they gotta be
shoveled snow shovel snow
well it's no not you shovel snow that
was part of your physical education yeah
and you did push-ups and sit-ups and
[ __ ] that's like russian chick bro
I'm sorry in the kitchen we didn't know
they were brutal
finally they built a gym in the eighth
grade yeah but before that we played
kickball outside in the fall when they
were getting playing kickball never
forget this the guys name was mr.
tortora that was the teacher's name was
he a good guy it was a good physical gym
pager and we're out there we're playing
kickball and again that little Italian
kid the one that invited me to his
father beat up the first dude we're
playing kickball he's throwing the ball
and every time I swing and I miss he's
calling me go go got it moco
that means I'm a boogie face in Spanish
cause it rhymes with Coco right and the
teacher keeps going Anthony I told you a
thousand times
none of that [ __ ] [ __ ] saliva this is
the sixth grade North Bergen New Jersey
a teacher school teacher mr. Tatar was
like hey let's pick a roof [ __ ] over
here right this is America right really
Oh bro that was at that time that was a
big issue because a couple weeks before
that a guy named cateura was a baseball
coach and he threw a kid off for
speaking Spanish on the bus he told to
me there's no Spanish on the bus and the
kid goes [ __ ] you and he spoke Spanish
they threw him off like 20 miles in the
house became a big problem in my
hometown they were gonna kill the
[ __ ] do it but I remember going home
my mom going he's talking the truth and
now she speaks Spanish this is America
outside you speak American so my mom cut
me off right there like I went home like
ready to [ __ ] be like a protester she
was like that don't happen here were
Americans he wants to expand it's over
the house I think there's a real benefit
to being able to speak more than one
language definitely is yeah completely
different my
said I'm happy I do it I speak to my
daughter in Spanish if I tell my ask him
mercy something I reactor in Spanish if
I science Irie Irie tolerance paradise